je
bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va
heures mais on ne va
parler sous le même
angle que d'habitude puisque on ne va
pas parler de la métaphysique de
schopenhauer et métaphysique qu'il
expose dans son livre le monde comme
volonté et comme représentation car
aujourd'hui on va parler de schopenhauer
sous l'angle de la rhétorique dont il
nous parle dans un tout petit livre qui
s'intitule l'art d'avoir toujours raison
alors il se trouve que ce livre est
aujourd'hui très connu au point
d'ailleurs que schopenhauer est
aujourd'hui davantage connu pour l'art
d'avoir toujours raison que pour le
monde comme volonté et comme
représentation
bon ça peut aussi s'expliquer par le
fait que le monde comme volonté et comme
représentation c'est à peu près 1200
pages tandis que l'art d'avoir toujours
raison
c'est un petit livre qui tient en une
vingtaine ou une trentaine de pages donc
ça peut expliquer le succès de cet
ouvrage par rapport à son ouvrage de
métaphysique
l'art d'avoir toujours raison a été
publié en 1864 et ce livre regroupe 38
stratagème 38 stratagème pour gagner le
débat 38 stratagème pour avoir toujours
raison face à un adversaire
donc aujourd'hui on va s'intéresser à
cette dialectique éristique c'est à dire
à ces stratagèmes assez technique assez
ruse pour gagner un débat
alors évidemment on peut noter la
dimension sarcastique de schopenhauer
donc ce livre mais en réalité il serait
très réducteur de résumer le livre à
cette dimension sarcastique
c'est à dire que le but de ce livre
c'est aussi de proposer au lecteur un
manuel d'autodéfense rhétorique et
intellectuels qui va vous permettre de
détecter dans le discours de vos
interlocuteurs
tout ce qui va être de l'ordre des
arguments fallacieux des sophismes ou
même des techniques de comportement pour
prendre le dessus sur l'autre dans la
discussion
les stratagèmes de schopenhauer sont
donc à la fois des stratagèmes
intellectuelle mais aussi des
stratagèmes psychologique parce
qu'évidemment la discussion intègre une
dimension psychologique
c'est à dire que dans un débat les
émotions jouent un rôle les émotions ont
une influence sur notre manière de
réagir aux arguments notre interlocuteur
et donc si on veut gagner un des barbes
il faut forcément tenir compte de cette
dimension émotionnelle du débat il faut
tenir compte de la dimension
psychologique de la dispute
intellectuelle alors je disais que ce
serait une erreur de réduire le livre de
schopenhauer à une simple dénonciation
sarcastique de la malhonnêteté
intellectuelle est en effet schopenhauer
dit lui-même dans l'introduction à son
ouvrage qu'il est parfois nécessaire de
recourir à ce genre de procédés pour
défendre nos idées
qu'est ce qui fait dire ça à
schopenhauer et bien c'est tout
simplement le fait que parfois une idée
vrai l'idée juste et condamné à ne pas
être entendue donc condamné à
l'impuissance
si elle n'est pas défendu avec des armes
rhétorique efficace autrement dit pour
schopenhauer
la vérité ne suffit pas toujours et à ce
moment là il peut être utile de recourir
à des artifices rhétoriques qui vont
permettre à nos idées de gagner du
terrain
la fonction du débat remet ce n'est pas
de chercher la vérité la fonction du
débat c'est de faire triompher notre
vérité notre conception de la vérité
le but d'un débat c'est de convaincre et
convaincre c'est combattre
c'est combattre l'adversaire et
combattre l'adversaire c'est mettre en
place toute une série de techniques pour
rendre son propos moins convaincant
c'est lui opposer des arguments de telle
sorte que ces arguments vont perdre de
leur efficacité et de leur puissance de
persuasion
remarquez d'ailleurs comme le champ
lexical du débat est un champ lexical
guerrier je parlais à l'instant
d'opposer des arguments mais on parle
également de confrontation d'idées de
stratégies argumentatives d'armes
intellectuelle et de gagner le débat
donc ici schopenhauer ne se place pas du
tout dans une perspective philosophique
d'investigation du vrai il ne s'inscrit
pas dans la démarche socratique de la
dialectique de la vérité il s'inscrit
dans la dialectique éristique
c'est-à-dire dans l'art de la
controverse
alors pour ceux qui auront envie de lire
le livre je vous invite très fortement à
ne pas sauter l'introduction je vous
recommande vivement de lire
l'introduction parce que schopenhauer y
explique d'où vient notre besoin d'avoir
raison a fortiori d'avoir raison face à
quelqu'un et davantage encore en public
schopenhauer nous explique qu'en fait
c'est tout simplement lié à la nature
même de l'être humain et à une
caractéristique de l'être humain
caractéristique innée qui est la vanité
la vanité c'est l'inconsistance c'est le
fait d'être moins intéressés par le fond
des choses que par l'apparence
extérieure des choses d'être moins
intéressé par la vérité que par l'image
de nos idées
c'est la logique des apparences la
vanité c'est ce qui fait que l'être
humain préféra toujours avoir tort mais
remporter les loges qu'avoir raison et
recevoir la réprobation l'être humain
préfère les louanges à la vérité il
préfère le succès à la sagesse et c'est
pour ça que l'être humain a recours à la
rhétorique et qu'il n'hésite pas à jouer
sur les apparences pour emporter
l'adhésion du public
à cela il faut ajouter que l'être humain
a une tendance à l'obstination dans
l'erreur
c'est à dire que lorsque nous sommes
dans l'erreur il n'y a rien de pire que
de le reconnaître
pourquoi et bien tout simplement parce
qu'on considère que ça va nous faire
perdre en crédibilité et que donc c'est
un aveu de faiblesse
on considère que reconnaître une erreur
c'est prêter le flanc aux attaques
donc on préférera toujours s'obstiner
dans l'erreur quitte à faire preuve de
la plus grande des mauvaise foi du
moment qu'on peut sauver les apparences
l'être humain pense que les apparences
le sauveront
il pense que les autres ne détecteront
pas la fraude et que du moment qu'il
défend ses positions obstinément il
finira toujours par s'en sortir
bien sûr c'est une illusion mais c'est
un besoin
nous avons besoin de prouver que nous
avons raison mais nous avons besoin de
nous prouver que nous avons raison quand
on argumente avec zèle contre
n'argumente avec offensive it et ou avec
agressivité
ce n'est finalement pas tant l'autre que
nous cherchons à convaincre c'est nous
mêmes
nous voulons nous convaincre que nous
avons raison que c'est notre manière de
penser qu est la bonne parce qu'il en va
de notre estime de nous mêmes parce
qu'il en va de notre image de nous-mêmes
et c'est pourquoi nous avons sans cesse
besoin de nous justifier vis-à-vis de
nous-mêmes de nous persuader que nous
sommes dans le vrai
on pourrait comparer les croyances
humaines à un édifice qui menacerait de
s'effondrer si on retirait un étage
l'être humain passe toute sa vie à
construire un système de croyances à
système de lecture et de compréhension
du monde
une fois que ce système est construit il
est hors de question d'en changer
il est hors de question de remettre en
cause ce système
donc on préférera toujours colmater les
fissures montée des échafaudages pour
tenter de rendre cohérent un système qui
ne l'est plus pour tenter de se
convaincre que notre système est le bon
dans tous les cas il est hors de
question de laisser notre édifice de
croyance se laisser détruire
parce que sans ce système de croyances
nous ne sommes plus à l'abri
nous devenons vulnérables
nous sommes en danger
la malhonnêteté intellectuelle la
mauvaise foi le délit le mensonge
parfois des stratégies inconsciente qui
répondent d'abord un besoin de repères à
partir du moment où on vit avec les
autres on a besoin de repères
on a besoin de repères auxquels on va
s'identifier à ceux auxquels on va se
définir
et c'est très important de pouvoir se
se définir auprès des autres se définir
auprès de soi même c'est ce qui fait
qu'on va très souvent défendre des idées
non pas parce qu'elles sont vraies mais
pour défendre une conception nous mêmes
et pour défendre l'image à laquelle on
veut correspondre une autre manière de
le dire c'est que on peut être de
mauvaise foi de bonne foi
on peut par exemple être certain d'avoir
raison pour justifier le recours à des
arguments fallacieux
mais le fait qu'on s'identifier à des
croyances fait qu'on va défendre ces
croyances comme si on défend des notre
propre vie et quand il s'agit de
défendre sa vie on ne se pose pas la
question de savoir qui a raison et qui a
tort
on défend sa vie
et pour défendre sa vie mme tous les
coups sont permis
que les armes sont bonnes à prendre et
donc l'appréciation de la valeur d'un
argument ne va pas se faire par rapport
à sa conformité aux vrais elle va se
faire par rapport à notre conviction
profonde et aux besoins que nous avons
de croire dans cette idée
c'est ce qui fait d'ailleurs qu'on est
beaucoup plus tolérants envers des
arguments qui vont dans notre sens y
compris quand ce sont des arguments
médiocre quand vers des arguments qui
s'opposent à notre vision du monde
je m'estime faire partie d'un camp en
lutte contre un autre camp si je me
reconnais dans un parti dans un
mouvement d'idées dans un clan je vais
me refusé à reconnaître la valeur des
arguments du clan opposé
je vais considérer que tout argument qui
émanera de ce clan sera forcément nul et
non avenu
c'est la logique même du militantisme
le militant ne pense pas parce que
penser c'est se donner l'occasion de
changer d'avis
et donc d'être dans l'inconfort voir
l'insécurité psychique
c'est à dire de voir apparaître une
fissure dans l'édifice de nos croyances
reconnaître qu'on a tort c'est très
difficile c'est très difficile car c'est
un aveu de faiblesse
en tout cas c'est ainsi que nous le
voyons c'est ainsi que nous le voyons
parce que nous avons une vision de
l'échangé intellectuel comme étant une
lutte pour la reconnaissance
c'est une des que développe le
philosophe hegel qui parle de
l'affrontement des consciences qui sont
chacune en lutte pour la reconnaissance
nous avons besoin que les autres
conscience nous reconnaissent et c'est à
ce moment là que la dispute
intellectuelle cesse d'être un
intellectuel pour devenir une lutte
d'égos une lutte pour la survie
reçoit la vie comme une lutte permanente
reconnaître qu'on a tort s'est prêté le
flanc à l'ennemi
et se mettre à découvert
c'est risquer la mort
on veut croire que la vie est une guerre
parce qu'à la guerre tous les coups sont
permis et c'est toujours plus facile
d'assumer notre agressivité
quand on part du principe que l'autre
nous veut du mal
dans cette vidéo on ne va pas se pencher
sur tous les stratagèmes présenté par
schopenhauer dans son livre on va
s'intéresser à 5 stratagème parmi les
plus utilisés par nous tous au quotidien
donc le but ça va être de réviser nos
classiques de manière un petit peu
amusante pour mieux détecter les pièges
rhétorique dans lesquels on ne manquera
pas de vouloir vous faire tomber
donc on y va on va commencer avec le
premier stratagème que j'ai retenu pour
cette vidéo le stratagème numéro 8
fâché l'adversaire soyez gentil de me
laisser parler et de cesser d'intervenir
incessamment un peu comme le roquet
écoute je n'ai pas parlé premier
ministre de la france
alors ça c'est un stratagème que j'aime
beaucoup parce que justement il met en
évidence que l'art de la controverse
ce n'est pas seulement l'art de manier
les armes de la rhétorique
ce n'est pas seulement savoir maîtriser
le langage c'est aussi savoir provoquer
des émotions c'est aussi savoir excité
l'adversaire le faire sortir de son
calme faire sortir de sa raison le rôle
donné par les romantiques à
l'appartenance face à l'idéologie d'un
homme des lumières des conçu comme son
propre fondement le mythe selon lequel
le débat intellectuel reposerait
seulement sur l'affrontement d'idées pur
c'est quelque chose que n'importe quelle
personne ayant pratiqué le débat ne peut
plus croire
l'expression de nos idées et toujours
influencé par nos émotions
or il n'ya rien de plus volatile il n'y
a rien de plus influençables qu'une
émotion
mettre l'autre en colère ça peut passer
par des moyens très différents
un bon moyen de mettre l'autre en colère
c'est de faire preuve de mépris
mépris envers sa personne ou même mépris
envers les propos qu'il tient parce que
notre tendance naturelle qui consiste à
nous identifier à nos idées fait que
lorsque nos idées sont attaqués on va le
prendre pour une attaque personnelle
derrière le mépris à l'égard de nos
idées ce que nous ressentons c'est un
mépris à l'égard de notre personne
ce montré méprisant ça n'a pas besoin de
passer par les mots ça passe d'abord par
une attitude une manière par exemple de
soutenir le regard de l'interlocuteur ou
de l'ignorer nous ferons tous les soirs
bat monsieur sarkozy et vous battre vous
d'ailleurs vous ne servez à rien le plus
tard entente a distillé de la haine
voilà tout ce que vous faites alors face
à ce stratagème
évidemment je ne peux que vous
conseiller d'employer la méthode
stoïcienne la méthode qui consiste à
vous détacher émotionnellement de votre
interlocuteur à faire abstraction de ces
réactions abstraction de tous et signe
de mépris parce qu'évidemment plus vous
serez détaché émotionnellement des
réactions de votre adversaire et plus
vous pourrez contrer et retourner contre
lui
son stratagème puisqu'il n'ya rien de
plus agaçant et donc de plus efficace
que le mépris
en réponse au mépris votre médecin me
laisse indifférent vun impressionné
d'aucune manière et j'ai en effet
l'intention de combattre en femme partie
de votre femme politique par
pouvons-nous toile deuxième stratagème
sur lequel on va se pencher stratagème
numéro 12
choisir des métaphores favorable alors
le titre de ce stratagème est un petit
peu trompeur parce qu'en réalité ce dont
parle schopenhauer dans ce stratagème
c'est le vocabulaire c'est le choix des
mots qu'on utilise pour désigner les
choses dont on parle ce que nous dit
schopenhauer
c'est que les mots qu'on utilise portent
en eux une connotation une connotation
qui peut être positive ou négative et le
but du jeu ça va être d'exploiter la
connotation d'un mot pour pouvoir mieux
faire passer nos idées et réfuté les
arguments de l'adversaire après avoir
été inséminée artificiellement quatre
fois on lui aura pris sont vos quatre
fois donc on va pouvoir parler après
aussi du problème qu'il ya de séparer un
enfant de sa mère
enfants oui c'est un enfant c'est un
procès l'enfant de la vache ça si un
enfant
enfin tout cas de mon dieu c'est quelque
chose que je défendrai schopenhauer
donne plusieurs exemples
et parmi ces exemples il donne le couple
de mots protestants hérétiques
il nous dit que le mot protestant a été
créée par les protestants alors que le
mot hérétiques
c'est un mot qui a été créée par les
catholiques pour désigner les
protestants de manière péjorative
donc il est certain que si au lieu
d'employer le mot protestants vous
employer le mot hérétiques
mais déjà vous induisent et une certaine
opinion à certains jugements à l'égard
des protestants vous induisent et une
connotation négative qui va préparer le
terrain en quelque sorte à la critique
que vous allez en faire donc c'est une
manière non pas de déformer la réalité
mais de la désigner sous un angle qui
est favorable à vos intérêts
schopenhauer donne d'autres exemples il
parle des mots de religion et de
superstition ça c'est quelque chose
qu'on retrouve beaucoup dans les textes
des philosophes des lumières au xviiie
siècle dans lesquelles ce n'est pas
directement la religion qui est attaquée
parce qu'à l'époque le mot religion
conserver forme de respectabilité
alors que parler de superstition c'est
une manière de disqualifier la pratique
religieuse
c'est une manière de la frappé du sceau
de l'ignorance et de l'immaturité
c'est une manière de reléguer la
religion à une forme d'obscurantisme un
obscurantisme dont il devient alors
légitime de se moquer si on voulait
prendre des exemples contemporains
on pourrait parler de l'emploi du mot
dictateur si un conflit armé s'engage
entre deux nations du monde dont l'une
est considérée comme une dictature et
l'autre comme une démocratie mais il est
évident que si vous commencez à vouloir
critiquer le président de ladite
démocratie là ce moment là vous pouvez
vous attendre à recevoir un reproche qui
risque de mettre à mal votre
argumentation
puisque votre adversaire ne manquera pas
de vous faire remarquer que vous dites
du bien d'un dictateur et dire du bien
d'un dictateur c'est évidemment être
dans le camp du mal
qu'à partir de là les possibilités
argumentative se réduisent à ce
moment-là vous est pris au piège des
mots il va devenir très difficile de
remporter le débat du cèdre donc vous
voyez que indépendamment de ce qu'on
pourrait dire le simple fait d'utiliser
un mot plutôt qu'un autre
pas forcément orienté la perception de
ce qui va être dit et d'une certaine
manière ça consiste à placer la
conclusion avant le raisonnement
d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'écrit
schopenhauer dans ce stratagème il écrit
au final il s'agit là d'une pétition de
principe
ce qui n'a pas été démontrée est utilisé
comme postulat pour en tirer un jugement
donc c'est pour ça qu'il faut toujours
se montrer très attentif aux maux qui
sont utilisés sont montrés très
attentifs et très vigilant sur la
terminologie pour désigner les choses
parce que très souvent les mots sont des
pièges
et se montrer attentif au mot
qu'utilisent l'interlocuteur c'est aussi
une manière de pointer le choix de ses
mots pour mettre en évidence sa
stratégie on est en train de trouver des
périodicités du soleil qui font que oui
ça s'est réchauffé mais la démonstration
que c'est le gaz carbonique
ce qui est possible n'est pas maintenant
alors quand vous me dites négationniste
je sais ça fait référence intérêts pense
à la shoah et je pense que dire cela on
va pas ce qu'on va pas se battre ici je
je pense qu'il est injuste de
l'assurance et diversité c'est ce qui
fait que george orwell est redevenu
autant la mode c'est parce que le
novlangue dans son roman 1984 est une
illustration de la manipulation de
l'opinion que l'on peut faire à travers
le langage parce que le langage c ce qui
structure la pensée
c'est donc ce qui structure l'opinion et
que si on utilise un vocabulaire qui
sert à propager notre vision du monde
on a déjà fait le plus gros du travail
la première des choses à faire lorsqu'un
mot est utilisé à la place d'un autre
ces deux points telle usage de ce mot
pour mettre en pleine lumière tout ce
qu'ils présupposent tout ce qu'il
sous-entend et pour montrer que le choix
de ce monde n'est peut-être pas anodin
ce qui me dérange c'est la bêtise de
ceux qui utilisent un mot qui sont
incapables de définir parce que populis
et quoi est ce que quelqu'un veut bien
donner le mal de décrire ce que c'est
parce que au moins 10 des finitions
possibles et figurez vous que je me suis
renseigné avant de dire un jour par
manière de plaisanterie à vos collègues
de l'express qui m'a interrogé en osant
vous voulez rendre vos lettres de
noblesse ou populistes de gauche comme
je sais pas ce qu'est le populisme
exactement de gauche ça m'a fait rire
j'ai dit bah écoute et populiste
j'assume pour une raison j'en ai assez
que toutes ces belles personnes se
donnent des grands airs en regardant le
peuple qui pourraient une masse confuse
et dangereuse
donc voilà pour ce deuxième stratagème
le stratagème numéro 12 choisir des
métaphores favorable stratagème suivant
le stratagème numéro 18 interrompre et
détourner le débat
si nous nous rendrons compte que
l'adversaire entrepris une série
d'arguments qui va mener à notre défaite
il ne faut pas lui permettre d'arriver à
la conclusion mais l'interrompre au
milieu de son argumentation
le distraire et dévié ce sujet pour
l'amener à d'autres alors ce stratagème
numéro 18
on peut le mettre en rapport avec le
stratagème numéro 29 faire diversion ça
c'est quelque chose qui arrive très
souvent lorsqu'on est face à un
interlocuteur qui ne maîtrise pas le
sujet et qui à partir du moment où on va
rentrer dans les aspects un peu
technique va tout de suite s'apercevoir
qu'il n'est pas au niveau et donc va
tout faire pour faire oublier de qu'on
parlait initialement
c'est pour ça que j'encourage toujours à
maîtriser les sujets dont vous parlez
pour ne pas vous retrouver dans ce genre
de situation c'est à dire à devoir
dévier la discussion faute d'arguments
parler sans cesse d'ailleurs parlons
d'heidegger autrement que dans la negra
c'est bienvenue ardi lorsqu'il a parlé
de partage celle du partage
théorie du bavardage scheidegger il
faudra le lire un jour et vous verrez d
une théorie du bavardage est une théorie
du enfin faut pas se contenter de parler
des gens sont là que vous allez devenir
ennuyeux et chacun son tour je propose
un débat traverse ne veut pas quand on
commence à parler du bavardage
scheidegger
il ya des trucs le monde quand on
maîtrise un sujet quand on l'a étudié en
profondeur
quand on a mis à l'épreuve de la
contradiction nos arguments sur le sujet
à ce moment là on ne craint plus la
contradiction on ne craint plus de se
faire déborder par les arguments de
l'autre et donc on n'a pas besoin de
faire dévier la discussion on n'a pas
besoin de détourner l'attention du sujet
et au cours de vos discussion
contradictoire vous pourrez vous rendre
compte que certaines personnes sont
spécialisés dans l'art de passer d'un
sujet à un autre dans l'art de la
discontinuité intellectuelle la
discontinuité intellectuelle c'est cette
capacité à passer à un autre sujet pile
au moment au sujet devenait intéressant
pile au moment où ça devenait nécessaire
d'aller dans le détail
en règle générale quand quelqu'un essaie
de dévier le débat
c'est une manière indirecte de
reconnaître son incompétence sur le
sujet donc ça c'est une occasion que
vous pouvez saisir pour retourner la
situation à votre avantage
une fois nous sommes vus pendant trois
minutes dans un débat on a eu que trois
minutes de débat sur campus et je vous
avais cité sur l'autre livre cinq fautes
de citations savez que vous m'aviez
répondu ce sont des coquilles des
coquilles de citations chacun
non mais là je vous en avais moi je ne
minimise et marcheuses et les classes je
souhaite finir j'ai fait une
encyclopédie tard à côté c'est pas
possible on m'avait demandé de terminer
mon raisonnement
elle est prise en flagrant délit d'un
truc énorme
chaque fois que vous êtes coincé vous
m'empêcher de parler pour vous donner
l'impression d'avoir et sont donc
maintenant vous allez me laisser
terminer
donc si quelqu'un vous interromps au
beau milieu d'un raisonnement pour vous
parler de quelque chose qui est annexes
dites vous bien que cette personne a
peut-être des raisons de craindre
votre argumentation parce que c'est
souvent quelque chose qui se produit
lorsqu'on maîtrise un sujet qu'on veut
rentrer dans le détail c'est que notre
interlocuteur n'a pas toujours envie
d'aller sur ce terrain il préfère rester
à la surface des choses
donc là encore il est très facile de
retourner ce stratagème contre votre
adversaire faire remarquer qu'il est en
train de détourner le débat et en
profiter pour lui demander s'il n'aurait
pas peur d'aller au fond du sujet
en faisant ça vous éviterez non
seulement de tomber dans son piège mais
en plus vous mettrez en évidence le
piège dans lequel il a essayé de faire
tomber ce qui aura pour effet de vous
faire prendre l'aventage dans la
discussion
puisqu'il n'ya rien de plus humiliant et
de plus discréditant que de voir le
piège qu'on avait tendu à l'autre mis en
pleine lumière détourner le débat parce
qu'on n'est pas capable de répondre à
une question parce qu'on ne veut pas
faire aveu de notre ignorance
c'est quelque chose de très facile à
détecter
et donc à ce moment là c'est à vous de
retourner le stratagème à votre profit
l'attaqué qui consiste à vouloir qu en
permanence parce que ça vous gêne
interrompt pour essayer de déstabiliser
l'adversaire
elle ne sert à rien car ce n'est
certainement pas monsieur fabius qui
allait me déstabiliser vous l'imaginez
bien stratagème suivant c'est le
stratagème numéro 25
trouver une exception alors celui-là je
les aime beaucoup parce qu'on est à une
époque où dès qu'on généralise
dès qu'on essaie d'étendre son propos au
delà des cas particuliers eh bien on est
très souvent rappelé à cette exception
exception qui aurait pour effet
d'invalider la règle générale est dans
une société du droit à la différence
dans une société où l'on cultive l'art
de la distinction la généralisation a
mauvaise presse
la généralisation c'est quelque chose
qui est perçu comme une sorte de mépris
comme une sorte de rejet des cas
particuliers et c'est un stratagème très
pratique parce que dans les faits il
n'existe que des cas particuliers et
donc dès qu'on se risque à faire une
généralisation il est clair qu'il y à
des cas particuliers qui ne vont pas se
retrouver dans la règle générale
donc c'est l'exemple bien connu du cygne
noir
le cygne noir étant l'exception qui
invalide la règle selon laquelle tous
les signes sont blancs on peut prendre
également l'exemple du poisson volant
parce que c'est vrai qu'il existe des
poissons volants mais en règle générale
les poissons n'ont pas d'elle finalement
c'est assez simple de réfuter une
affirmation général parce qu'on peut
toujours trouver une exception à la
règle
mais la question est de savoir quand on
pointe une exception à la règle
est-ce qu'on invalide la règle
que des casses s'écarte de la règle
c'est très facile à concevoir
évidemment qu'il y aura toujours des cas
pour s'écarter de la règle
il existe des non fumeurs qui meurent du
cancer du poumon on trouvera toujours
des cas particuliers
mais lorsqu'on débat de choses général
est à proprement parler on peut
d'ailleurs débattre que deux choses
général parce que si on parle que des
exceptions on ne peut rien déduire
par définition la pensée généralisante
est donc l'expression de la pensée passe
forcément par des généralités
parce qu'à ce moment là qu'est ce que ça
veut dire ça veut dire par exemple que
la cigarette n'est pas dangereuse pour
la santé
elle n'est pas dangereuse pour la santé
puisqu'il y à des fumeurs qui n'ont pas
de cancer du poumon dont voyez dès qu'on
s'interdit de généraliser on en vient à
dire des absurdités on en vient à nier
des évidences et cette terreur de la
généralisation
cette peur de manquer de respect aux
exceptions elle est liée à une confusion
absolument terrible entre la
généralisation et la stigmatisation
l'idée qui est sous-entendu c'est que
lorsqu'on généralise on exclut le cas
particulier on exclut l'exception
mais enfin lexicalement parlant le mot
même d'exception ça veut dire ce qui est
exclu
ça veut dire ce qu'on retire de la règle
générale est ce que ça veut dire pour
autant que la règle n'existe pas non ça
veut dire qu'il existe une règle est
qu'il existe des cas qui sortent de
cette règle sans que cela n'invalide la
règle
faut bien qu'ils aient une règle pour
pouvoir sortir de la règle il faut bien
qu'il y ait une généralité
pour qu'il y ait des exceptions à la
généralité imaginons que 10000 cancéreux
ayant vu la promotion de votre méthode
sur les réseaux décide de vous faire
confiance
votre approche fonctionnant mal 9900
décède et censure vivent concrètement la
seule chose que vous vivrez de votre
côté c'est une pluie de 100 témoignages
positifs
remerciements et incitation à promouvoir
davantage cette méthode afin de sauver
encore plus de gens le fait de citer
l'exception pour invalider la règle
n'invalide pas à la règle
le fait de citer l'exception permet de
nuancer la règle de la relativiser mais
en aucun cas de l'invalider
on en arrivera au jour où dire qu il
fait plus froid en hiver qu'en été sera
considérée comme une stigmatisation
envers l'été
donc si votre interlocuteur vous
reproche de généraliser et qu'il prétend
réfuté votre argumentation en citant une
exception à ce moment-là retourner lui
l'argument avec les exemples que je vous
ai cité et on verra à ce moment-là si
votre interlocuteur accorde autant de
valeur que ça aux exceptions
et enfin dernier stratagème mon préféré
le stratagème numéro 32 principe de
l'association dégradantes
lorsque l'on est confronté à une
assertion de l'adversaire il ya une
façon de l'écarter rapidement ou du
moins de jeter l'opprobre dessus en la
plaçant dans une catégorie péjorative
même si l'association n'est qu'apparente
ou très ténue
alors pourquoi est ce que je dis que ce
stratagème est mon préféré parce qu'il
me semble que c'est celui qui a le plus
souvent cours dans les débats
contemporains et notamment dans les
débats politiques
c'est une technique qui est devenu très
commune pour discréditer un propos de
mentionner la proximité de son auteur
avec des courants des écoles de pensée
ou des mouvements politiques
unanimement considéré comme
infréquentable d'ailleurs c'est un mot
qu'on retrouve très souvent
fréquentation comme si le fait de
fréquenter quelqu'un signifier qu on
adhérait à sa pensée qu'on partageait sa
vision du monde
astrid stuckey l'auberge est médecin et
chercheuse elle fréquente là qu'on peut
faire d'internet comme emma cruzy on est
ici de cette vidéo
michel rosenzweig du philosophe mais
surtout le psychanalyste écrit dans le
magazine des nexus qui est je cite un
magazine de désinformation et d'apologie
sectaire source qui flirte avec le
négationnisme et pathos d'absolution
c'est le complotisme ressources
notons que d'autres intervenants du film
ont écrit dans la revue lexus et les cas
de ariane bilheran de wemmel tco 2 bis
ou d'une dalle et des rivaux miguel
bartoli
il fait des conférences avec la
naturopathe hygiéniste irène grosjean
laquelle affirme notamment que les virus
sont bénéfiques
on évoque également dans une vidéo
précédente et sa dame est surveillé par
les associations antisectes voilà le
milieu où évolue ce monsieur tout ce
petit monde donc évolué dans les mêmes
sphères les mêmes aux endroits où la
crédibilité la fiabilité n'est pas
forcément un mètre - tous ces mots tout
ce champ lexical de la proximité être
proche de tels mouvements flirter avec
telle idée tout ce champ lexical
s'inscrit dans ce même stratagème celui
du déshonneur par association quand
votre interlocuteur a recours à ce
stratagème
c'est qu'il n'a rien à dire sur le fond
c'est qu'il n'a rien trouvé dans vos
propos dans vos paroles qui soit de
nature à pouvoir vous être reproché
parce que croyez moi bien que si votre
adversaire avait trouvé dans vos propos
quelque chose qu'ils pourraient vous
reprocher il ne se fatiguerait pas à
relever vos proximité a évoqué vos
fréquentations
il ne dirait pas que vos idées flirte
avec tel courant de pensée il ne dirait
pas que vous êtes proche de tels groupes
jugés infréquentables
il se contenterait de montrer en quoi ce
sont vos idées qui pose problème
non pas qu'ils vous fréquentez n'ont pas
de qui vous êtes proche
encore faudrait-il définir ce qu'on
appelle proches
que proche ça veut dire avoir déjà
rencontré
est ce que ça veut dire être amis vivre
sous le même toit
qu'est ce que ça veut dire être proche
parce que moi quand je vais au
restaurant etc on sert une assiette avec
une entrecôte et des frites mais frites
sont proches de l'entrecôte
peut-être que mes frites sont en fait de
la viande puisqu'elles sont proches
votre frère
à
justifiée expliqué trouver des bonnes
raisons à la lapidation des femmes
adultères reproché la proximité de
quelqu'un avec un groupe un courant de
pensée où un individu quelconque c'est
faire un aveu d'impuissance
c'est dire qu'on n'a rien à dire
c'est à dire qu'on n'a aucun argument
pour contrer l'idée mais qu'on veut
quand même jeté un peu la suspicion sur
vos idées la voix rien à reprocher mais
essayez quand même
trouver une prise pour pouvoir
disqualifié de penser non pas sur le
fond mais sur son appartenance supposée
à une catégorie je suis désolé mais
quand j'ai lu ce livre que vous avez
écrit avec alain soral un fort avec
alain soral je suis encore plus désolé
pour vous tous ceux qui ont lu le livre
le savent je me pose point par point à
la pensée de soi alors vous me faites un
procès en compromissions écoutez si vous
voulez parce que là on parle de la
liberté d'expression vous êtes
complaisant mais je me suis absolument
sans mentionner la vous avez écrit ça
avec lui un des pc avec lui il sait
soral je lui réponds je le contredisent
à bsg jésus ni à chaque phrase ou
d'indignation mais je partage votre
indignation va pas refaire le bouquin je
partage votre indignation
je ne recherche pas vos déconnade donc
n'hésitez pas si jamais on cherche à
discréditer vos propos en faisant valoir
votre proximité avec tel ou tel groupe
n'hésitez pas à demander à votre
interlocuteur quelles sont mes arguments
quelles sont mes propos quelles sont mes
idées que vous contestez
et si votre interlocuteur cherche à
détourner la question voire stratagème
18 fait lui remarquer et rappelait lui
que si le but d'un débat et de
confronter des idées
il n'y a pas lieu de chercher en dehors
des idées des choses à vous reprocher
c'est plus facile de dire le choix et
les fascistes de tout poil c'est les
mêmes c'est rouge brun c'est la même
clique qui contestent la république qui
contestent le système de domination et
donc ne l'écouté pas c'est un fasciste
alors une fois qu'on a des choix
réfléchis on arrive à ne plus parler
avec lui on n'arrive plus à on a on n'a
plus l'obligation d'argumenter en a plus
on n'est plus obligé de discuter mais
dont qu'on a on a disqualifié le
messager pour pas avoir à discuter du
message en conclusion notre besoin
d'avoir raison traduit en fait notre
fragilité notre vulnérabilité et notre
désir de reconnaissance
lorsqu'on a confiance en soi et en ce
que l'on pense lorsque l'on est détaché
notre image et du jugement des autres
on n'a pas besoin d'avoir raison et on a
encore moins besoin de montrer qu'on a
raison
lorsqu'on est uniquement intéressé par
la vérité notre seul besoin c'est
d'agrandir notre champ de compréhension
du monde
en socrate disait tout ce que je sais
c'est que je ne sais rien il voulait
dire notamment que la connaissance est
faite d'allers et retours
d'abord on ne sait pas puis on croit
savoir
puis on s'aperçoit que notre savoir
n'était pas la vérité alors on fait
évoluer notre savoir et à mesure que
notre savoir évolué on prend conscience
que ce savoir n'est que croyance et
qu'un jour il sera contredit
sera remis en cause et mis à l'épreuve
plus on comprend les choses plus notre
conscience progresse et moins nous nous
identifions à nos croyances
moi nous éprouvons le besoin de nous
battre pour faire reconnaître ce que
nous pensons
parce qu'alors nous cessons de nous
définir par nos idées ses idées
auxquelles nous tenons tant ses idées
qui sont comme la peau de notre esprit
ses idées sans lesquels pensons nous
nous ne sommes plus rien
lutte permanente pour la reconnaissance
la reconnaissance des autres mais aussi
la reconnaissance de nous mêmes notre
besoin d'avoir raison c'est notre besoin
de combler le puzzle des autres avec les
pièces de notre propre puzzle
et d'insister et de forcer si la pièce
ne s'emboîtent pas
le besoin d'avoir raison c'est le besoin
de se conférer une légitimité
c'est le besoin de se protéger et de se
confronter au monde pour ne pas avoir à
se confronter à soi
c'est le besoin de pouvoir continuer à
vivre sans avoir à affronter les
questions dérangeantes
celle qui nous pousserait à la remise en
question
celle qui menace de faire vaciller notre
système de croyances le faire vaciller
ce que nous avons mis des années à
construire et à consolider
pour le voir finalement on s'effondrer
savoir ne dispense de croire et savoir
que ce que nous croyons n'est que ce que
nous croyons c'est savoir qu'en réalité
nos croyances ne s'effondre jamais
elles se transforment elles mûrissent
suivent le cours de leur existence
évoluant nos croyances ne meurt pas
elles montrent qu'elles sont vivantes
une croyance qui évolue n'est pas une
croyance qui meurt
une croyance qui évolue est une croyance
qui vive
je vous remercie
[Musique]